salut aujourd'hui je suis à la maison il
ya laurent tardieu qui est venu pour
m'interviewer l'idée aujourd'hui laurent
c'est un truc que j'ai jamais fait je
suis pas certain de réussir à me faire
mon but c'est de trouver ton code de
carte bleue un code pin tueur choisi toi
même ton code de carte bleue c'est que
le code de carte bleue tu le choisit pas
il est imposé par l'avant côté
est ce que ça te fait stresser ou pas un
petit peu je hais ce que tu me fait
confiance je me sens vraiment comment on
va faire un truc dans un premier temps
je vais je vais écrire dénombré des
chiffres ici toi tu vas penser au
premier numéro de la carte bleue c'est
tout et quand je vais l'écrire
le premier numéro de carte bleue tu dis
stop dans ta tête unique noté dans ma
tête donc toi tu regardes ici et moi je
te regarde toi on est dans le champ
ouais j'ai cru un imagine le côté jean
toi est-ce que ça finit par un nombre
pair c'est dire halte obligée de la
gauche molle
non mais moi j'ai dû tourner inquiète
pas je sais que sept minutes à un
chiffre impair
d'ailleurs ce peut être un chiffre fort
ou un chiffre
parce que ça peut être très haut très
bas et très haut merci ok je pense que
j'ai à peu près tout ce qu'il faut on
arrive à la difficulté de prouver que je
pense connaître au moins trois chiffres
sur lesquels je peux pas leur dire était
demandé si c'est bon et si je te fais
lire sur un bout de papier ça fait un
peu fait il ya un distributeur à côté de
chez moi
six à dix on y va j'essaie de retirer
par jag là à dire et c'est bon allez
prenez parti se tiraillent où j'emmène
avec moi c'est parti on vient de me dire
ça car expire en janvier 2010 est donc
si si j'ai le bon numéro je pense qu'il
va plus jamais essayé par réaction du
quatrième je pense qu'ils se suivent je
pense comme dans un deux trois quatre
fils et deux il veut plus venir
je te regarde plus je dis plus rien
il ya une petite banque en face c'est
parfait pour nous
toute la presqu'île
on a un petit distributeur ici
est ce que tu peux sortir la carte bleue
site de claire
je l'apprends j'essaie de retirer d'un
euro et si ça marche pas si tu as pas
liés
te propose de reculer un petit peu pour
me filmer avec la caméra comme ça on
verra que
ça marche pas en voir le coach ça marche
il ya trois essais il ya trois et cinq
au pire je peux essayer deux si jamais
j'ai bloqué ma carte à leur tour écran
oh
g
il faut que j'appuie sur rien non je
verrai ce étonnant
carte bleue non
et comment
comment
je trouve quand même que je rend
l'argent et la carte bleue
ah oui
mais allez déchiré ma carte
je vais faire opposition directe
sa maladie
que
je promets solennellement de ne jamais
dire ton code de carte bleue
par contre je l'écrirai dans les
commentaires je mentirais si vous vous
abonnez à la chaîne en fait au moment où
vous abonner ou que et que vous cliquez
sur le bouton abonne toi a certainement
vous recevez le code de laurent théry
vous irez pas loin ça va merci je suis
sur le cul tu penses à la maison ben
ouais leon retourne la mise au rebut des
affaires d'avoir les affres et puis
avec ta carte bleue
a lâché sur lui comment tu peux écouter
72 24
ne croyez pas ça ne lui tende et pas un
guet-apens et esata plus à coups de
vandales merci en tout cas à vous
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo hésitez pas
vraiment à faire un tour sur le blog une
petite pièce s'il vous plaît que pierre
laurent une pièce s'il vous plaît donc
sa part des pièces de spectacle mais pas
que je vous mets le lien dans la
description tu veux devenir mon corps
d'enfant pour les sous types si vous
voulez participer je suis en train
d'ouvrir la possibilité de ce qui ferait
toutes les vidéos c'est collaboratif
donc ça ça dépend que de vous en faite
ça permettrait que que les malentendants
puis suivent les vidéos et voire même
les gens qui ne parlent pas français
donc ça je trouve ça cool c'est à vous
de voir qu'on se retrouve son spectacle
soit sur le mental blog et la prochaine
vidéo c'est demain à 17 heures